en plein cœur du quartier d'affaires de
La Défense la salle à manger est un
restaurant pas comme les autres à la
fois solidaire et éco-responsable il
propose des repas à petit prix cuisinés
à partir d'un vendus donnés par les
supermarchés ou les traiteurs du coin on
va les laisser réduire
comme ça
des produits frais qui seront périmés
dans quelques jours et doivent donc être
utilisés le plus vite possible un défi
pour l'équipe qui doit se réinventer au
quotidien au menu aujourd'hui paupiettes
de veau et risotto aux champignons
c'est un challenge mais c'est très
intéressant
en coulisses le chaînon manquant assure
le lien entre donateur et bénéficiaires
cette association est née en 2014 après
l'obligation faite aux grandes surfaces
de données leurs invendus alimentaires
alors j'ai aussi des fruits et des
légumes les amis en France 8 millions de
personnes sont en insécurité alimentaire
alors que 10 millions de tonnes de
nourriture sont jetés chaque année pour
moi c'est une fierté donc de lutter
contre le gaspillage alimentaire quand
on voit les quantités justement qui sont
gaspillées et quand on voit la précarité
alimentaire c'est vraiment un crève-cœur
moi j'ai été éduqué aussi à l'anti-gaspi
de par ma mère ont jetait jamais rien à
la maison donc c'est pour moi c'est un
bon sens
ouverte depuis novembre 2021 la salle a
mangé fait souvent sale comble ici tout
est fait maison et les clients
apprécient autant la qualité des plats
que la démarche anti-gaspi
c'est tellement mortel
c'est beau c'est propre
l'ambiance l'accueil les plats
la défense c'est vraiment le temple du
gaspillage mais
ultra consommation notamment tous les
restaurants qui se trouvent dans le
centre commercial c'est beaucoup
beaucoup énormément de gaspi beaucoup de
malbouffe et là on arrive à faire
autrement un prix acceptable avec une
bonne qualité et sans jeter des produits
à vous
si le gaspillage alimentaire était un
pays ce serait le troisième plus gros
émetteur de gaz à effet de serre au
monde derrière les États-Unis et la
Chine conscient des enjeux le restaurant
fait le maximum pour limiter les pertes
les restes sont pesés en fin de service
afin d'ajuster les quantités servile et
fois suivantes
l'objectif final évidemment c'est que ce
bac un jour soit vide
on va y travailler mais on est déjà
extrêmement heureux de voir que pour 80
couverts on arrive à cette conclusion
c'est déjà à magique et on est très fier
de ce qu'on fait
autre initiative les familles zéro
gâchis Morgan nourri mettent en pratique
cette démarche éco-responsable au
quotidien elle en a même fait son métier
je rentre des courses on fait les
courses régulièrement plusieurs fois par
semaine on a cette chance d'être près
des commerces quand on rentre on range
tout de suite dans le dans le frigo
évidemment et puis on a ce petit
pense-bête que nous a donné la
communauté d'agglomération quand on
faisait les les familles dérogaspi qui
nous dit bien qu'il faut mettre en haut
là où c'est le plus frais la viande et
le poisson ensuite les produits laitiers
et ensuite bon là j'ai acheté des
légumes donc forcément ils vont dans le
bac à légumes
établir des menus faire les courses
régulièrement privilégiez les produits
secs non périssables mettre les
épluchures au compost ou encore cuisiner
les restes ou les congeler la jeune
femme déborde d'imagination quand il
s'agit d'éviter le gaspillage les
croûtons c'est parfait parce que c'est
une recette très simple on sait jamais
quoi faire avec nos morceaux de pain
nous reste de pain de pain qui qui
durcissent qui raciste et quand je fais
une soupe je les fais revenir à la poêle
avec de l'huile d'olive et des herbes ça
permet de d'avoir des super croûtons
pour les soupes
des gestes simples aussi facilement
adoptés par son compagnon
donc il faut se parfois c'est se guérir
soi-même de dire on va peut-être manquer
non on va pas manquer aujourd'hui le
couple ne jette presque plus rien une
façon à leur échelle de lutter contre le
changement climatique quand on a les
chiffres en tête que on sait que quand
on jette une baguette de pain c'est
comme si on vidait une baignoire d'eau
parce que il a fallu beaucoup d'eau pour
pour faire pousser le blé on se dit on
va même plus jeter notre quignon de pain
on va le garder ça a une telle valeur ça
demande tellement de ressources que que
on le garde à l'échelle mondiale 6% des
ressources en eau et 30% des terres
agricoles sont utilisées pour produire
de la nourriture qui sera perdue ou
jetée et deux tiers de cette nourriture
et gaspiller avant même d'arriver
jusqu'au consommateurs producteur
industriels et distributeur doivent donc
agir eux aussi Michael marchand l'a bien
compris ce boulanger a investi dans
cette machine aussi simple une
révolutionnaire
voilà c'est parti une sorte de broyeur
qui réduit le pain dur en miettes pour
en faire de la chapelure
vraiment le but c'est d'arrêter les
invendus et depuis qu'on a cette machine
c'est 100% du pain qui a été récupéré
cette chapelure est ensuite un corporée
dans une recette spécialement conçue
pour ce nouvel ingrédient pour Mickaël
marchand les copains c'est un
savoir-faire boulanger en réponse aux
problématiques actuelles
je veux dire je fais d'une tradition et
je mets de la chapelure dessus en disant
ah c'est écolo génial c'est pas ça ce
qui nous a poussé c'est comment résoudre
le problème des déchets on veut
satisfaire avec client mais on veut pas
détruire la planète donc comment on fait
en boutique les copains est un succès et
pas seulement en raison de son petit
prix il est bon quand il y a des
commerces qui font ce genre de démarche
on essaie de les favoriser
chaque année dans le monde 3,3 giga
tonnes de CO2 équivalent sont rejetés
dans l'atmosphère pour produire de la
nourriture qui sera gaspillée c'est
presque autant que la totalité du
transport routier mondial